les élections c'est un peu votre domaine
d'expertisé vous avez été secrétaire
adjoint aux élections au sein du ps et
vous n'aimez pas qu'on dise en parlant
des dernières municipales qu'on a
assisté à une vague verte pourquoi c'est
pas que j'aime ou j'aime pas la
politique s'est passé il ya des faits il
y à une progression et moi je suis
heureux que quand des partenaires
progresse il ya une progression
manif est notable et sensible d'europe
écologie les verts
et après il faut regarder la réalité de
l'ensemble des municipales aujourd'hui
si on prend la gauche le premier réseau
d'élu local et de très très très très
loin c'est le parti sioniste donc le
parti à l'iss depuis 2014 ces dernières
élections nous avons progressé dans mon
département par exemple est donc partout
et je pourrais citer beaucoup de gens je
viens à michaël delafosse à montpellier
mathieu klein à nancy et je prends dans
le lit de france vous êtes par exemple
le vin karim - bram à saint-ouen
méli'môme mathieu nault tincani on a
déjà zaz à châtillon belle victoire et
puis dans mon département d'esprit de
morat a besoin je vous en serais
beaucoup d'autres donc à une nouvelle
génération qui arrive des choses c'est
une bonne chose
voilà donc moi je ne vais pas d'accord
avec olivier forbes pour vous c'est il
est hors de question de se mettre à la
remorque des écologistes pour les envies
des prochaines élections
avant mon positionnement n'est pas par
rapport à untel ou untel je respecte
j'ai beaucoup d'amitié pour l'effort
premiers secrétaires du persuadé je dis
simplement que l'élection de la
prochaine élection présidentielle elle
sera très important d'entre eux pays et
je crois que les socialistes mais il
faut renouveler notre pensée il faut un
projet socialiste et jeux pour réseaux
et donc en france manger derrière un
candidat sociales écologistes comme le
dit olivier faure moi je ne sais pas ce
qu un nom via sociale écologiste
jusqu'à preuve du contraire par
socialiste est un parti europe ecologie
qu'il faut un candidat socialement je
pense qu'aujourd'hui je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les verts et apporte une
réponse partielle à son de
problématiques et je crois que nous
socialistes avant de réponse plus
globale il faut réinventer fois un
nouveau projet socialiste pour la france
et après on discutera que les
partenaires et moi je pense que si
j'étais avec les jeux si je pensais que
ce que propose socialiste était plus
opérants que ce qu'est la social
démocratie
je serai chez les verts je suis
socialiste parce que je pense que la
question de l'égalité
la question sociale la question de
l'émancipation la laïcité etc et
milliards une priorité majeure dont je
suis socialiste et je pense que ce
projet-là correspond mieux aux français
qu'un autre projet ça me semble juste
cohérent
je crois que je crois quand vous êtes
militant d'un parti politique peut le
comprendre et non avec les socialistes
et les écologistes à vous plaindre
donc moi je le pense qu'il faut faire
par étapes première chose c'est un
projet socialiste parce que je pense
qu'il faut je pense que tu représentes
aux français ce qui est notre vision
pour la france pour le monde pour
l'europe
ça c'est le premier point après s'il ya
une primaire de la gauche
faisons là mais sinon s'il n'y a pas de
primaire s'il n'y a pas que les
socialistes qu'elle serait donc la forme
et à méthode pour désigner un candidat